-Our guests tonight, one of th
biggest groups on the planet
Their new album
"Map of the Soul: 7" is out now.
BTS right here!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
-Hey.
-Okay.
-♪♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪♪
♪♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪♪
-If you're in New York,
you have to go
to the greatest place to eat
and that is Katz's Deli.
That's where we are.
Let's get some food.
Let's do it! Yeah!
-Whoa!
-Very heavy.
[ Laughter ]
-Pastrami?
-Pastrami.
-But no veggies?
-No veggies. No.
Are you kidding me? No.
-Hey, hey, hey. No ketchup
-No ketchup?
Oh.
-Get out of here with ketchup.
-[ Laughs ]
-What is the go-to food
in Korea?
-Spicy fried chicken.
-What if, like, late at night,
you feel like having a snack
-Chicken.
-Chicken is the way to go.
Right?
-Chicken and beer.
-[ Laughs ]
-Cheers.
-New Yorkers, like, scarfing
like, "I'm so for the business."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I love
the movie "Home Alone."
-"Home Alone"?
-Yeah.
-That's classic --
That's a classic in Korea.
-No. "Home Alone"?
-Aah!
You know the face?
-Macaulay Culkin?
-Aah!
-Really?
Who is the hammiest
out of all of you guys?
-Um...
[ Laughter ]
Okay, um, um...
Oh, yeah.
-Easy, easy.
-How has it been coming
to the United States
and having people respond
to your music?
-I love you, army.
-J-Hope, without BTS,
what would you be?
-Tennis player?
-Tennis?
Tennis.
-Ha!
-Hyah!
-Ho! Ho!
-Ha!
-Oh!
-Ho!
-Out of three teams.
-Three teams, three teams.
-He got bronze.
-Jin, how about you?
-I'm actor.
-You wanted to be an actor
-Yeah.
-Aaaaaaah!
-No, no, you can't don't d
"Home Alone."
Already did that.
♪♪♪♪
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
-Are you, Jin?
-Get him! Get him!
-Whooh whooh whooh whooh -
-Get him!
whooh whooh whooh whooh
whooh! Oh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Bell dinging ]
-Winner!
♪♪♪♪
-Jin wins!
-No-o-o-o-o-o-o-
o-o-o-o-o-o!
No-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o
-Jimin, what would you do?
Host a talk show?
-Oh, maybe.
-Don't take my job.
Don't take my job.
-Oh!
♪♪♪♪
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
-Hey, my son.
-[Laughs]
-Oh!
-Ohhhhh!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Laughter ]
-I got him, yeah?
-Hey!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Jimmy wins!
-V, what about you?
-Saxophonist.
-Saxophonist?
-Oooooooh!
-Like here?
Saxophone?
-Yeah.
-Do we have a saxophone?
[ Laughter ]
What's the George Michael?
What's that?
[ Scat singing
"Careless Whisper" ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
[ Scat singing
"Careless Whisper" ]
[ Squeak ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Ohhhhhhh!
-V wins!
♪♪♪♪
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
-Wah ah ah ah!
[ BTS oohs ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, SUGA!
-Wow! Wow!
[ Rubber duck squeaking ]
-Jungkook wins!
What is the black bean
noodle incident?
-Yeah.
-[Laughs]
-I had a stomachache, so.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-How long did you go away?
-I don't know.
Like three or four minutes
That's not that long.
It's like...
and, you know, I was like,
"Get me noodles as fast
as you can," and, you know
it was just --
-It was so fast.
-Order up!
-Go!
[ Voices overlapping ]
-[Speaks indistinctly]
Yo! Hey! What's happenin'?
-Order u-u-u-u-u-u-up!
[ Voices overlapping ]
Oh, no. I'm comin'!
I'm comin'! I'm comin'!
[ Voices overlapping ]
Me and BTS.
Please enjoy. Enjoy.
[ Voices overlapping ]
-Jimmy!
Jimmy!
Move it! Move it!
♪♪♪♪
-Yeah!
Good work.
-Let's go.
[ Laughter ]
-Guys.
I'm not fooling around.
You are going to perform
at Grand Central
right now, tonight.
It's legendary.
So enough of the sandwiches.
Let's go to Grand Central
and put on a show!
Let's do it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah!
♪♪♪♪
[ Shouting ]
Whoo-hoo!
-Go. Let's go.
Is there something you do
before every performance?
Can you show me?
-You wanna do it together?
-I'll do it with ya.
-Okay.
-C'mere.
-So,
we go down.
We don't go up.
So we don't go down.
When I say...
...and you guys say...
You say -- [Speaking Korean]
-[Speaking Korean]
-Yeah. So when I say
[Speaking Korean]
you say [Speaking Korean]
Okay? We go down.
♪♪♪♪
-Whoo!
Wow!
BTS!
Grand Central Terminal.
"Map of the Soul: 7"
is out now!